see you uh promoting the [ __ ] out of
this new record you were with the einer
banks which is like you know always a
big deal you pull out the guy with the
ukulele yeah yeah yeah he went guitar on
me this time you got the prosthetic
hearts and stuff yeah man yeah yeah fake
hearts and all that type of [ __ ] like
that
um
albums coming this is the setup for the
album you've been putting out singles
yeah this this more so like a setup for
the EP okay so it's an EP because you
have what's that same job Body Work 2020
20 21 so last year last year but it
wasn't like it wasn't no
it wasn't an album I haven't dropped the
album like ever ever so we're
considering everything mixtapes
everything in the label size that's
important yeah right because they want
to be like now you always out those are
mixtapes yeah yeah so I got like I got
like three mixtapes out listen man uh
I'm super proud of you yeah I saw you
post today uh some of like the just
progression in the live shows you've
been doing yeah yeah yeah yeah I
remember when you first signed you came
up to the station and I feel like you
were getting like all these like baby
comparisons which didn't make any sense
because you guys would make the same
kind of music but like you guys are on
the same label and you know some people
say you might look like his little
brother yeah right
um but like you've carved out your own
lane I feel like um I feel like you kind
of had your own genre of like what you
do yeah I feel like that's that's kind
of like you know the fight with
everything right now like the fight with
everything right now it's kind of like
um
standing out he is standing out in who I
am as an artist you know like you got
you know people from my label wanting
wanting me to be like one thing and then
you got my fans who perceive me as you
know another and what my fans perceive
me is you know that's why I truly am
so like and what is that
um
the lover boy yeah I feel like if you
want to hear about some love [ __ ] or
some heartbreak [ __ ] your music is where
you go yeah man I mean I'm a lover boy
you know I mean I I ain't perfect but
I'm the loving boy though yeah I mean
but the fans look at me like that way
yeah you know that's what I truly am but
you know they've got people at the label
who want me to you know they see the
tattoos the the grills they they know my
background they know what I come from
and they want me to be like well you
you've been through this you did this
you
all right but I'm not that though do you
feel like you're getting pressured from
the label to do different [ __ ] oh
yeah somewhat yeah I mean is that
frustrating nah because I had I had to
get to a point where it's like you know
um
I kind of like just stepped away from
that yeah held up started recording uh
for myself
and now we just present it to him when
it's ready I feel like
if you were to do
more of what everyone else is doing it
wouldn't be as special no like we don't
need another NBA young boy no and no
disrespect to him we don't need like we
like we like I feel like we need more
music about relationships and emotions
and love I feel like that's what's
missing yeah I mean and that's what
that's was I think that's kind of like
what's special about you know
um what what I'm doing I mean because
there's not a lot of artists that
everybody want to be tough nowadays you
know I'm not saying that you know the
artist now you're super vulnerable on
records you're very like I just feel
like like I feel like you're fill in a
void man I feel like you know I know
Diddy I mean and listen you kind of do
like a of hybrid hip-hop r b thing like
yeah I wouldn't put you in any box like
a mix but I feel like that's what's
missing like I feel like you know
there's very few artists we're getting
that from and I feel like the way you
deliver it is what makes it the most
unique you know almost death most deaf I
mean it's I don't know bro it's it's I'm
definitely a once in a lifetime thing
like it's it's not it'd never be another
artist like me um it'll never be another
artist that's willing to take the steps
that I'm willing to take that's gonna
put their life on I know whether I'm
gonna put my life on the line it'd just
never be another artist like me but it
it'll be somebody close to me probably